welcome back to cbs mornings for
millions of people who've gotten covet
some symptoms lurk and linger for months
even years including body aches brain
fog and heart palpitations it's called
long covered and it's affecting some
people on capitol hill one of them
senator tim kaine he's on a mission to
seek help for americans like him scott
mcfarland joins us with senator kaine's
story very interesting he's coming
forward now scott good morning
tony good morning to you two years into
the pandemic members of congress
acknowledge they're coming up short when
it comes to helping patients with long
covid senator kane included who says
this is personal to him
literally the day i got covered i just
felt like
my nerve endings all woke up they'd all
had five cups of coffee and they were
just tingling and buzzing 24 7 and
that's never gone away tim kaine came
close to being a heartbeat away from the
presidency in 2016. then in spring 2020
the former democratic vice presidential
nominee and current virginia senator
became one of the first prominent
politicians to test positive for covid
now nearly two years later he's still
fighting it what does it feel like i
feel like you drop an alka-seltzer in
the water and just watch it fizz it kind
of feels like that it just kind of feels
like a fizzing or buzzing nonstop in
your hands in your feet oh everywhere so
i mean i can feel it in the tip of my
forehead right now i can feel it along
the tops of my legs his symptoms are
distinctive but patients reporting long
covered symptoms are not at all unique
others experience brain fog persistent
cough and permanent loss of taste or
smell affecting up to 23 million
americans i used to exercise with my dad
every morning at five o'clock before i
went to work it was a whole routine
maddie smith is one of them the marian
virginia mom of three boys and traveling
nurse who says more than a year after
contracting the virus it's still a fight
to lift herself out of bed each morning
the worst part for me thus far is the
coveted fatigue and that was one of the
worst symptoms i had when i had covid
and i guess i kept thinking it would get
better and it's
never gotten better smith needs an
inhaler for breathing troubles but for
months wouldn't tell anyone worried
she'd be viewed as a complainer you're
suggesting people with long covet may be
hesitant to say it
absolutely concerned about the reaction
i think they're concerned they won't be
taken seriously earlier this month the
white house announced plans to boost
research into long-covered and possible
treatments senator kaine has proposed a
new law that goes even further to fund
more research and compile a more
accurate count of long-covered patients
and help people get access to care
including in rural america just over the
virginia border in eastern tennessee
nurse practitioner pam poor says her
long-covered patients often need to see
neurologists for memory problems or
cardiologists for heart symptoms in an
area where specialists are difficult to
find we have so many patients that need
to be referred to specialists
but the waiting lists are long there's
another hurdle in this area vaccine
hesitancy remains rampant and many are
reluctant to seek tests or care for
symptoms that aren't life-threatening
senator kane says his legislation would
also require the cdc to reach out to
people experiencing potential
long-covered symptoms and encourage them
to seek treatment some don't even want
to admit it like man i code was bad
enough maybe i did tell somebody they
didn't believe me or they told me it was
just anxiety it's in your head yeah
somebody told me i told my doctor hey
i've lost my sense of taste or smell
haven't gotten it back in a year okay
how about an anxiety medication no i'm
not anxious i'm a happy person i just
can't smell or taste anything
congress is still deadlocked over a
separate coveted bill a 10 billion
dollar bill to pay for therapeutics and
treatments and emergency needs so this
new long coveted legislation could be a
very long political fight as well
gail
oh man scott i've heard that long covet
is no joke thank you so much that's why
guys when people say oh if i get coveted
it's no big deal i'll be able to recover
chances are you're right about that but
then you could be that case where you're
months later talking about long codes
yeah and it's a role the dice and it's
not about loss of life in that case it's
about loss of quality quality of your
life 23 million americans who are
suffering from long covet so it's it's a
huge number yeah you imagine losing your
taste or smell
no i cannot no no
please don't want that to happen please